how do you how do you deal with people
like the haters because there's so many
people I call them thumb thugs but how
do you deal you just there to hatin in
the dark I don't know what they're doing
you don't read all those comments see I
don't read shit anymore man
yeah very very rarely going to mentions
if I do it's usually a mistake I just I
just do my best do my best I post and I
go I post and ghost you don't even look
at people's feeds do you know I look at
some people's fear and when I'm bored
yeah you know I'll read some things you
know I look at some cool pictures i
watch some inspirational shit I like
going to the rocks seeing him with
Toulouse me pumped up wanna go to the
gym let me let me tell you Fletcher I
interviewed the rock the first time I
met him was like 11 years ago during the
game plan and we just hit it off right
game playing the game plan that's where
he played a quarterback he was a lot
thinner you know his his first breakout
movie okay that put out a disc or pinion
and in the game plan and after that
interview he took some time and just
talked to me he wasn't the rock didn't
let me it was me
and then over the years every time I
interviewed him he would pull me aside
and go are you going to my acting coach
are you doing this are you doing that is
there anything I can help you with
and I'm like why like and then he got
bigger and bigger in the last time I saw
him same thing yo are you doing are you
going into acting coach are you working
on your goals are you improving
like literally his Instagram but in real
life and I'm and it's and he'll never
know this but it's a thing that's for me
just average mo Michael yo to take the
time out every time I interview him to
ask me if I'm achieving my goals if I'm
moving forward and like giving me
positive things positive thoughts to
take that time like five minutes after
every interview and this dude is booked
non-stop but to actually take time and
it's just so inspirational in to see him
be the biggest movie star in the world
and he knows everybody's name he's very
respected I don't know if he has an
earpiece but like he's like the
president when he knows everybody's name
he could be President he Cassander
percent a hundred percent of the
president said he can perform I would
too because he but he's just awesome
comes from humble beginnings yes you
mean he's in Hawaii right now and he's
filming on his
Graham's talking about all the
neighborhoods that he goes back to to
check to see where he was worst from
when he was poor and starving yeah you
know I mean he really is from humble
beginnings I mean he had only like you
know it's the story like five dollars
left in his account and then he got
discovered in wrestling and I knew him
in Miami when he was doing WWE I
interviewed him a couple times over
there and and he played for the
University of Miami my favorite college
football team so it's a thing where you
know the history of 11 years but for him
that big to take time to motivate me
separately and you know I know if he
sees me out he knows my name but it's
not like I'm texting uh I'm not like
Kevin Hart with him and just to be a
random dude that he takes time out every
time he sees me to make sure I'm hitting
my goals and moving forward with my
career and not back and then offering
hey if you ever need anything get in
touch with me you know I would never
take him up on that but it's a thing
where I'm nobody
he's the rock and to be that inspiration
it just does so much man
like it little things that big
celebrities do or somebody that really
inspires you like they don't know how
much that means like just so just that
little time he spends yeah at least I
think he does know I think he's a
genuine leader he is you know it's I
think that's why so many people like him
because what he says is it's authentic
like it's really who he is
there is nothing fake about that man I
don't have to be fake you just have to
be successful and if you want to work as
hard as that guy you could be successful
I I asked one day I was like do you just
take a bunch of pictures at the gym like
didn't just post throughout the day
because you're always get that big from
taking pictures oh man that guy's
picking heavy shit up that's too bit but
you know what I love that's just too big
he's an action star dude and he's the
first action star that looks like an act
like I would love him to save my life in
real life Wow he's what is he like six
seven or something
his giant he's a little bit taller me
I'm 16
yes giant he's built like a fucking like
a legitimate superhero like Will Smith
was my guy but I left Will Smith for the
ryeom you left him no no I stayed he
stuff well no I did no no but like like
a do what you gotta do
a burning building a burning burner
who's gonna save you who's gonna save
you
well spent might save you two aliens
coming at you
Independence Day did you not see Will
Smith look I love Will Smith but in an
earthquake well if you want someone to
hold one hand on the top of a building
cue and then hold your wrist with
another and know that he's got you
according to the movie poster that's the
rock see I never saw Will Smith holding
the top of buildings well Smith by the
hand Will Smith to shoot a gun those
those zombies he did I am Legend oh man
what a great move a fucking move oh my
goodness fuck God